[Music]
all right here's our video of the day
look at your screen a restaurant owner
in los angeles is being hailed as a good
samaritan after he took down a suspected
robber who attacked an elderly man
earlier this month now the thief who's
believed to be homeless took the
victim's phone and wallet in broad
daylight when restaurant owner tim
ratcliffe chased him down and held them
before police arrived about 10 minutes
later now the lapd says there they are
adding 200 more officers to the
hollywood division as crime continues to
spiral out of control well maybe if
kamala harris didn't praise the
defunding of the lapd maybe we can
protect more people
of course it is only the latest example
of far-left policy failures in major
cities as residents in urban precincts
all across the country continue to
suffer under far left failed leadership
for example out minneapolis the teachers
union there has reached a new agreement
which stipulates that white teachers are
to be laid off first regardless of their
seniority what appears to be blatantly
racist and unlawful here with reaction
out kick founder clay travis with leo
2.0 tarot i don't know leo to me that's
simple basic fundamental discrimination
101 racism 101. your
first for 30 years i've been fighting
for equality of the civil rights
attorney and that's inequality that's
backwards you're 100 correct it's racist
it's discriminatory it's illegal and it
should be invalidated immediately i read
what the union said they said they want
students to have teachers that look like
them wrong
the students need teachers who will
educate them
educate not what they look like it is
insulting that people are going to be
judged based on color and more
importantly john color determines
qualifications wrong skill talent
experience professionalism this is
basically an extreme leftist socialist
agenda on this equality critical race
nonsense it's illegal and should be
invalidated immediately
this would be institutionalizing racism
clay
yeah of course it would and i agree with
everything leo said look the foundation
of the democrat party now is two things
uh sean it is everything is racist and
america is an awful place that is
basically everything that the democrats
believe and if you drill down
essentially every policy that they
advocate for that's what it is at its
essence it's wrong we're going to see a
supreme court case this fall that deals
with meritocracy versus affirmative
action actually focused to a large
extent on asian kids and so what we're
going to see i believe is we're going to
move back towards equality and repudiate
and reject this idea of equity which has
taken over if you notice they don't talk
about equality anymore they talk about
equity which is a fundamentally
different uh notion and so the democrat
party broken at its core and this is
perfect evidence of it in a city that
has been riven
with all sorts of flaws associated with
attempting to be as woke as they
possibly can and leo as a lawyer
why would they open themselves up for
such a a clear clean discrimination
lawsuit that will cost them tens of
millions of dollars
because they don't care logic is out the
window they are trying to i read the
article they're trying to make this a
national model it's going to get stopped
at the first doorstep the one last point
sean is this the assumption that people
of color got shortchanged i have a
bachelor's degree i have a master's
degree i had a law degree
it wasn't the color of the teacher was
irrelevant it was whether or not that
teacher was competent and i'm thank you
very much i don't need to see a
color for for a teacher i want to see
the skill set but it's insulting to
every african-american or any person of
color that you need a person of color to
teach you i reject that
i would imagine a big loss to clay last
10 seconds yours
yeah 100 i'm with leo i went to public
school here in nashville i had
phenomenal teachers who were black i had
phenomenal teachers who were white you
know how many times i thought about the
race of the teacher zero i thought about
are they making sense and making me
smarter that's what every parent cares
about i was always thinking how hard are
they going to make this test i don't
feel like studying that hard
but anyway leo thank you clay thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else